ah
[Música]
a
la campaña de vacunación en francia
comenzó el 27 de diciembre con las dosis
del laboratorio alemán biotech facer y
se dio prioridad a las personas
residentes en hogares de ancianos a los
discapacitados que están también
internados y el personal de salud de más
de 50 años que trabaja con este tipo de
pacientes sin embargo cuatro días
después sólo 332 personas habían sido
inmunizadas en francia y el país se
encontraba en el número 24 de la lista
de los países que habían comenzado a
vacunar a sus ciudadanos las críticas
vinieron y por lo mismo esta semana el
ministro de salud tuvo que comparecer
frente al senado el reconoció
efectivamente equivalent y tus problemas
de comunicación quizás por prudencia ya
que según la encuesta ipsos del 29 de
diciembre cuatro de cada diez franceses
apenas se decía dispuesto a vacunarse
otros dicen que es culpa de la
burocracia francesa simplemente y otros
que fue porque este país pasó su comanda
junto a la unión europea que lo hizo
demasiado tarde lo cierto es que aseguró
el ministro hay dosis y material
suficiente para vacunar de aquí a fin de
mes a un millón de personas el 18 de
enero comenzarán a vacunarse las
personas mayores de 75 años
[Música]
el programa de vacunación en alemania ha
sido recibido con esperanza en
particular por quienes lo ven como el
principio del fin de la pandemia el
principio del fin también de esas
restricciones estrictas que aún siguen
vigentes aquí en alemania pero también
ha sido recibido con muchas críticas
algunas de las regiones han criticado en
particular al gobierno federal porque
consideran que la distribución de la
vacuna ha sido demasiado lenta y que no
han recibido suficientes dosis el
gobierno federal ha defendido su
política de vacunación ha asegurado que
de hecho ya se conocía desde hace rato
que el comienzo de este programa iba a
ser difícil ya ha explicado que todos
los alemanes que así lo quieran van a
poder recibir la vacuna en el momento
adecuado las autoridades también han
visto con buenos ojos que a partir de
esta semana haya empezado a distribuirse
una segunda vacuna la de moderna y han
explicado que se comenzó el programa de
vacunación a finales de diciembre más de
750.000 personas han recibido la primera
dosis
[Música]
la meta del gobierno británico es
vacunar 2 millones de personas cada
semana para así a la mitad de febrero
haber vacunado 15 millones de las
personas más vulnerables a la fecha
desde que se inició esta campaña de
vacunación la más grande de la historia
en el reino unido se ha vacunado más de
2 millones y medio de personas la gran
crítica al gobierno hasta el momento es
porque no se está vacunando las 24 horas
del día siete días a la semana
el primer ministro boris johnson explicó
que el número de vacunas que llega al
país así no lo ha permitido pero que se
espera que rápidamente cambie esta
situación en esta estrategia ambiciosa
que tiene nueve etapas luego vendrán 21
millones de personas que se espera sean
inoculadas para la primavera y se espera
que gran parte de la población sobre los
18 años esté completamente inmunizada
para el otoño por supuesto requiere una
gran logística y siete grandes centros
de vacunación
a lo largo y ancho del país
[Música]